Este problema dice
evalúa 3x cuadrada -8x más 7, en "x" igual a -2 o sea básicamente
tenemos que cambiar todas las "x" de aquí por -2. Vamos a ver qué nos queda, nos quedaría 3
por aquí en vez de "x" va a -2, - 2 al cuadrado
-8 por en vez de esta "x" va un -2 más 7
Muy bien vamos a hacer las operaciones.
Aquí -2 al cuadrado es 4 por que menos por menos es más y 2 por 2 es 4 entonces, nos queda 3 por 4
-8 por -2 es -16 entonces lo voy a poner así -16 y luego tengo que sumar
7, más 7 ¿Muy bien? Vamos a ver qué nos queda, este 3 por 4 es un 12, lo voy a poner aquí 12,
aquí tenemos que restar -16 entonces es lo mismo que sumar
16, sumar 16 y finalmente hay que sumar ese 7.
Vamos a ver cuánto nos da, 12 con 16 es 28 y 28 más 7 es 35 entonces, la respuesta es 35.